these are the sort of frivolous people
who impeach the president
led by the most frivolous of all of them
alexandria ocasio-cortez
who just went on a long rant that is
both hilarious
but i think insightful she did not
realize it was insightful but she
unwittingly gave a lot of insight into
the way the left is thinking
so she opens up in this rant describing
the tragedy
of the scourge that we've been talking
about all week you know this is the
the incarnation of evil in america it's
a pervasive problem
white supremacy you know don't you feel
you're walking around it's like you're
surrounded by skinheads wherever you go
right right well no maybe you don't know
any skinheads maybe you don't know any
neo-nazis but i am reliably informed by
the democratic party that this country
is
teaming with skinheads 75 million of
them
at least right doesn't matter that you
don't know any of them
trust me that trump supporter that you
don't talk to very much but maybe you
saw him across the street
that guy is a neo-nazi that's the white
supremacy so aoc goes on
to describe the tragedy of white
supremacy they would rather
see our country burn
than to see them be shoulder-to-shoulder
equal to others
that is the tragedy of white supremacy
the tragedy of white supremacy
is that it is doomed to fail
it's doomed to fail white supremacists
will never ever
ever live in a world
where they will see their fantasies come
true
ever hold on a second here i think i was
listening to what she said
did aoc said the tragedy of white
supremacy is that it will fail
that is aoc a white supremacist did i
miss something i know
politics is changing a lot minute by
minute but am i to understand that aoc
considers it a tragedy that white
supremacy will fail
and i was trying to think i thought is
it is she describing tragedy in a sort
of
shakespearean set a literary sense you
know someone who starts off like really
great and real everything's working out
really really well and then it
completely collapses no
i don't think she would say that about
white supremacists i don't think she
considers
skinheads to be these sorts of you know
people where they're heroes and
everything's going great but then ah
some character flaw
makes it makes it not work she's saying
it the tragedy is that they're they're
doomed to fail because aoc not uh not
the brightest bulb in the pack however
however
she is very effective she is very
effective at
communicating her views to rile up her
base and to rile up
our base too right she's ex she is
singularly talented
at getting her radicals riled up but
also triggering all of us right i mean
that is that is kind of her
her singular uh feature and then she
gets a lot of headlines in conservative
media and that helps her become more
popular
and that helps her amass more influence
within the democratic party and it
really
really has worked out for her pretty
well so aoc spins a good yarn
aoc during this uh during this
rant it was part of a larger riff about
how she feared for her life
during the capital riot listen to her
harrowing tale
as for myself i had
a pretty traumatizing event
happen to me
and i do not know
if i can even disclose the full details
of that event
due to security concerns but
i can tell you that i had a very close
encounter where i thought i was going to
die
um and you have all of those
thoughts um
where you know at the end of your life
and all of these thoughts come rushing
to you
and um that's what happened to a lot of
us
on wednesday um
and i thought i i did not think
i did not know if i was going to make it
to the end of that day alive
a harrowing tale you remember aoc the
other day said that almost half of
congress died
and of course that isn't true no member
of congress died and
doesn't doesn't appear that any member
of congress came even close to dying
or really got so much as a scratch which
is good right we're very glad no member
of congress was injured
in in the riot and i have no doubt it
was very scary if you were a member of
congress i'm sure it was
terrifying you don't want to experience
that sort of thing now they're taking
riots really really seriously
however where was aoc's concern
when businesses were being burned
people's houses were being
burned when people's lives were being
threatened and ended
in city upon city upon city
this summer during the blm riots where
was aoc where was her concern then
well that was good wasn't it that was
the the cry of the oppressed masses that
was a wonderful thing that we
had to encourage in our words and for
some lawmakers
with our money kamala harris bailing the
riders out of jail so they could go burn
more businesses down
i bet those business owners were pretty
afraid i bet some of them
feared for their lives some innocent
people
lost their lives many innocent people
lost their lives during the riots
that the democrats encouraged
and and and made excuses for and said
were mostly peaceful
they weren't mostly peaceful if the riot
on capitol hill was a riot
if the ride on capitol hill was not
mostly peaceful certainly
the destruction we saw around the
country during blm was not mostly
peaceful
it's amazing these democratic lawmakers
they only seem to really worry when it
affects
them but then aoc goes on and
unwittingly gives a very important
insight into the left-wing ideology she
said
that the south is the democrats for the
taking
that's what we gotta do we gotta
organize
and i think what we saw in georgia
is a really good example
with black women leading the way
with multi-racial and multicultural
organizations leading the way
um we they proved
that southern states are not red states
they are suppressed states which means
the only way
that our country is going to heal is
through the actual liberation
of southern states the actual liberation
of the poor the actual liberation
of working people from economic social
and racial oppression
that's the only way southern states are
not red states they're
suppressed states this tells you so much
about the left's ideology and the way
the left views democracy
according to the left if they lose
elections
that is simply evidence that the
election
was completely illegitimate now the
right questions election sometimes too
but it's in a very very different
way aoc said something very important
during her rambly social media rant
she said that it is her view that
southern states are not red
states they are suppressed states
meaning that when you go in there and
you completely change the election laws
and you get rid of election day and make
it election season
and you have widespread mail-in ballots
and you take away the election integrity
measures that have been in place for
decades
then all of a sudden democrats win if
you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you